while people wait hours now in line for
tests in the las vegas area some are
deciding just to go ahead and drive to
get tested joe moeller is at a new
mobile site in sandy valley and he shows
us why some are going that extra mile
for a test
this is the first week a mobile site has
opened up here at the sandy valley
library people we talked to say it was
worth the hour drive to come here rather
than sit in a car at places like samboy
stadium
i jumped on it
right away i booked it it may take a
little while to get to sandy valley 50
minutes from my house at anthem in
henderson but people like paul sackley
say it was easier than searching around
vegas for a test southern nevada health
district locations are all booked for a
week curative is partnering with the
health district to operate a handful of
mobile sites this sandy valley van will
be outside the library tuesdays and
thursdays now appointments are made
online we decided to figure out where
sandy valley was
and took a drive everyone we talked to
was from las vegas or henderson marnie
garbo says their family did not have a
choice we needed to get a kova test for
her to go back to school because we were
exposed
and for my husband to go back to work
and so we looked
online and everything was full until
next monday or tuesday whether it's
sitting the car in a parking lot or
driving an hour oh it's insane
people never thought it would come to
this this is the only
location that i could get a covet test
this site is by appointment only today
they tested roughly 50 people the sandy
valley location is open on tuesdays and
thursdays on mondays wednesdays and
fridays it moves to laughlin reporting
in sandy valley joe mohler live local
now